У свої 20 років Руслан Топчан вчиться заново ходити.
Тут треба основне - навчитися тримати баланс.
Ну! Потихеньку-потихеньку!
У львівському центрі реабілітації "Незламні" він - один з наймолодших захисників, які сюди потрапили.
Про те, як втратив частини обох ніг, чоловік розповідає, на подив багатьох реабілітологів, з гумором.
Каже, якось з’їздив до Нью-Йорка. Але не американського.
А того, що на Донеччині, де точаться запеклі бої.
Ха-ха! Планую поїхати на протезування в Нью-Йорк!
Така паралель трошки! Там один день ти живеш, другий - ти можеш загинути!
В той день почався дуже жорстокий артилерійський обстріл, який тривав десь два дні.
Ми їх відбили, і в ході того, коли переміщалися, я наступив на розтяжку.
До повномасштабної війни Руслан був студентом третього курсу Національного університету біоресурсів і природокористування.
Мав стати землеупорядником.
Втім, 24 лютого 2022 року добровольцем пішов у ЗСУ.
Коли навесні 2023-го підірвався на розтяжці, пригадує Руслан, він попри біль лишався при тямі.
Що я зрозумів? Я так на хлопців глянув, я зрозумів, що в мене ножки, скоріше за все, уже не будуть працювати.
Десь годину я лежав без знеболювального, без нічого.
В ході довгої евакуації протягом восьми годин я тільки потрапив у Дніпро.
Десь після трьох стабілізаційних пунктів, після восьми годин, коли там все, можна сказати, вінегрет.
Мертві тканини просто.
З Дніпра Руслана вдалося оперативно доставити до Києва,
а після того, як рани трохи зажили, його прийняли у Львові, у центрі "Незламні".
Готуючи складну ампутацію обох ніг, Руслану дали можливість обрати один з варіантів безкоштовної операції -
вживлення імпланту або персональні зйомні протези.
Безпечнішим для юнака був другий варіант.
Операція минула успішно - тепер на черзі знайомство з протезами.
Ось це така частина, це називається "приймач", туди заходить сама частина ноги, далі йде механізм.
Коли в тебе є коліно, то тобі такого механізму не потрібно.
Він виконує саме функцію повороту коліна - ось!
Наступний етап відновлення хлопця - реабілітація і підготовка до життя з протезами.
Упродовж двох місяців Руслан Топчан живе у центрі "Незламні"
і ходить на фізичні заняття і тренування з протезами.
Це вправи і на посилення м’язів спини, і на координацію та рівновагу.
Ти коли стаєш на протези, в тебе повинна бути дуже сильно спина розпрацьована,
бо ти вже ходиш не за рахунок своїх кісток,
а за рахунок м’язів - сідничні м’язи, спинні м’язи, прес.
Отримати поранення - це 30 секунд. А стати на ноги - це місяці три-чотири.
В окремій залі - щоденні індивідуальні заняття з персональним реабілітологом.
А в деякі дні за розкладом - боулінг, арт-терапія, психологічні сеанси,
прогулянки, спортивні змагання та навіть курси англійської.
Постійно кудись виїжджаємо!
На тих вихідних виїжджали на "Ігри нескорених".
Постійно процедури, є досить хороші психотерапевти.
Оця вся заняттєва діяльність - це психологічне розвантаження.
Але якщо умовно говорити про боулінг, то це круто як і в аспекті ерготерапії,
тому що в нас є хлопці, які мають ампутовані верхні кінцівки,
і вони можуть спробувати, як це працювати умовно лівою,
коли ти все життя працював правою, зрозуміти, як по-новому функціонує тіло.
Центр "Незламні" почав працювати як державний реабілітаційний хаб
для військовослужбовців та цивільних ще до повномасштабної війни.
Втім, саме після вторгнення РФ, кажуть тут, потреба в реабілітації військових неспівмірно зросла.
Безкоштовну комплексну реабілітацію у центрі надають усім,
хто звертається напряму в проєкт або через волонтерів.
Підтримати ініціативу також може кожен охочий - донатом на сайті "Незламні".
У центр щомісяця приїздять іноземні делегації партнерів,
які фінансують проведення нових інноваційних операцій,
надання тренажерів, діагностичних пристроїв та біонічних протезів.
Сполучені Штати, Німеччина, Франція, Австралія, Ізраїль -
мені важко назвати країну, яка би не долучилася до допомоги.
На що ми збираємо гроші? Ми хочемо збудувати корпус.
Ми хочемо збудувати травмацентр.
Тема реабілітації зараз в державі є пріоритетною.
І це дуже важливо. І ми зараз "Незламними", мультидисциплінарним підходом -
у нас є протезування частиною або психіатрія частиною великої лікарні -
це є приклад для медичної системи України.
Зараз в інших медичних закладах буде реалізовуватись ця наша схема роботи.
Комплексна реабілітація - від моменту поранення до повернення у повсякденне життя -
це те, що зараз проходить і військовослужбовець Ігор Крупнов.
Після тяжкого поранення під Миколаєвом, йому першому в Україні вживили протези прямо у кістки ніг.
Сталося це завдяки львівським хірургам та їхньому австралійському колезі,
який спеціально приїхав у центр реабілітації "Незламні" на революційну операцію.
Результат класний! Маю унікальні протези, про які мріяв, чесно кажучи.
Коли стояло питання, які протези мають бути, то я, моя дружина, мій друг Денис пропрацювали,
дослідження зробили по темі протезування,
і з’ясувалося, що остео-інтеграційні протези більш функціональні.
Чоловік каже: першим згодився на новий вид протезування,
бо вірив, що його успіх у відновленні зможе надихнути інших.
Звідси виходять люди, яких я бачу, я з ними спілкуюся,
вони адаптовані до цивільного життя і вони живуть щасливим життям.
Для того, аби поранений боєць міг без переїздів лишатися в центрі і отримати тут всю допомогу,
в одному з корпусів будівлі збудували першу в Україні майстерню протезів,
яка обслуговує саме цей конкретний заклад.
За місяць тут роблять понад 20 різних індивідуальних протезів.
В лікарні це перша майстерня. Для того, щоб мати комплексну реабілітацію,
добре, щоб усі фахівці були поруч.
Ми збираємося командою, обговорюємо пацієнта,
вирішуємо, що кожен з нас може зробити на даному етапі.
Ok. I’ll keep it in mind.
Деякі техніки реабілітації для окремих пацієнтів львівські фахівці розробляють персонально із іноземними колегами онлайн.
Ось так зараз свої успіхи із новим протезом ноги на відео для спеціалістів з Хорватії записує Ілля Пилипенко.
На фронті він втратив одну кінцівку та зазнав опіків майже половини тіла -
в останню мить вибрався з палаючого танка.
Про свою травму говорить із сарказмом.
Я смажив картоплю, отака, знаєте, є сковорідка, "вок" називається.
Оце я підкидав, перекидав картоплю.
І випадково мене хтось позвав, і я послизнувся, впав.
Потім в лікарні дивлюся - нога переламана.
А якщо без жартів…
У військових, які втратили кінцівки, дуже велика проблема з фантомними болями.
Не всі знають, як з цим справлятися.
І тут є велика допомога в цьому. В плані психологів.
Я дуже задоволений, що я потрапив сюди.
Психологічна реабілітація - окрема частина програми відновлення у центрі "Незламні",
каже керівниця проєкту Ірина Заславець.
Мета - не лише дати людині проговорити травми з психологом,
а й допомогти звикнути до нового життя - у найменших деталях.
Для цього у одному з корпусів навіть створили окремий тренувальний майданчик - симулятор квартири.
Тут не те приміщення, де пацієнт заселяється і живе тиждень чи два.
Це про історію, коли він заходить і вчиться застеляти постіль.
Вчиться розвішувати речі, вчиться прасувати.
Тут все покликане відновлювати людину.
І так само зараз ще готується, ще не запущена, ще окрема кімната, яка є магазином.
Людина зможе собі взяти якийсь миючий, якусь крупу, скласти тацю, підійти до каси.
Це про вміння максимально повернутися в побут.
За час повномасштабної війни реабілітацію у центрі "Незламні" у Львові
пройшли понад 11 тисяч військових та цивільних.
20-річний Руслан Топчан каже: у цьому місці за один місяць перебування він знайшов друзів і тих, хто його підтримує.
Здоров! Як ти?
Ну, прогрес на лице!
Треба постійно тримати дух і розуміти, як ти правильно налаштуєшся, так воно і буде далі по життю!
Руслан Топчан будує плани на життя: після перемоги завершити навчання в університеті.
Але спершу, після відновлення в центрі, таки повернутися до лав ЗСУ -
у тій ролі, в якій він зможе бути корисним.